all right elijah
yes elijah where'd you grow up where are
you from originally nashville tennessee
well i was born in erie pennsylvania but
uh raised in nashville and tell me about
your childhood yeah both your parents
when you were a kid
initially yeah i had both my parents um
my uh my dad was really abusive um
physically abusive he said beat the
living hell out of my mom and
my mom was blamed uh or accused of
having an affair when
she was pregnant with me my father was a
military man
so i have two siblings and out of my two
siblings i was the one that was screamed
at and told i wasn't his
and i was heavily abused by my dad
he would run me up into a corner and
scream at me and tell me that i wasn't
his and uh beating me tall as black and
blue
so how many you have a total of two
siblings two yeah and of the three
two two real brothers two half brothers
one step brother two step sisters
all right so that as a transition
was your dad's suspicion correct that
your mom was pregnant with someone
else's child
my uncle says it's true my mom's brother
okay my mom denies it who knows
and uh what kind of kid were you in high
school
um i was troubled
um if you want to backtrack a little
sure when my mom got remarried my
my mom and my dad divorced when i was
about seven years old
it was just after i'd had my appendix
ruptured and i
almost died in the hospital anyway my
mom remarried my dad remarried
my mom's second husband was quite the
twisted guy
um just
do you want another stuff yeah yeah like
uh
some things he would come at you like i
remember one time he came out
it was me my mom my little brother
and my step-sister and he came and he
was he was a big
350-pound biker guy he came out and told
my mom and me and my brother and my
sister all to get naked
and sit together naked as a family said
that was how a family was supposed to be
together
later on that transitioned into
molestations
from what i understand there's 11 of us
total that even listed in the family
including you including me
it's a rough childhood yeah you left
home after
i was uh i was about
16 when i left home
i moved to florida
i got in a relationship
had a child got married
but uh still core values we actually got
married before my child was born um
that didn't turn out so well she had an
affair and got pregnant by another man
what part of florida was this st
augustine
so
we've actually never divorced we've been
married 21 years this year we've been
separated for 17.
you're still married still married
and you've had jobs yeah here and there
i've suffered with mental health i've
been diagnosed with
bipolar with rapid cycling and mixed
state obsessive-compulsive personality
disorder generalized anxiety disorder
post-traumatic stress disorder adhd and
agoraphobia
that's all that's all
so i've i've been in and out of mental
hospitals
since i was about 19 20.
and uh are drugs a part of your life
yeah
yeah i uh i'm not proud of it but i i do
crack heroin pills
the wormhole for drugs came when
i got with a woman i knew for 30 years
in tennessee
we went to elementary school middle
school
in high school together she was there
for me when i was going to the
molestations
so um she's always been someone that i
really cared about
um so anyways uh
years after years after
i moved away to florida and i came back
to tennessee
um we reconnected
um some more backstory my mom was a
severe alcoholic my whole life
she still is at any rate um i took care
of my mom for 10 years
and uh when me and my ex now
when we first got together i told my mom
that i was moving
and that she would have to move in with
one of my brothers
so she moved out and i moved in with my
now ex
and uh we were together for about four
years
um and the heartbreak there is
she was in the drugs and at the time all
i did was smoke marijuana
and i'd done a little bit of meth at
that time but i stopped doing
crystal meth and i just smoked marijuana
got into some legal trouble
um got put on probation so i danced
around probation doing drugs
my ex was in the crack she was in the
pills
and that escalated to heroin use
so um at any rate
covet hit 2020 she my ex is a nurse
she's an rn and uh
she has a compromised respiratory system
so
uh she stopped working and she made
ninety thousand dollars a year so
we spent thirty thousand dollars a year
on drugs at least
and when she quit working everything
kind of fell apart and we relied on my
income
and i didn't have a vehicle and she
wrecked hers taking me to work so i lost
my job
and so drugs were slow and coming
and there was no work i had no way to
get back and forth and she wasn't
working because of her compromised
respiratory system due to you know with
the fear of covid
so uh we broke up last july
and uh that's where i fell way down the
wormhole
and uh i became homeless on the streets
of nashville
and uh
got heavy into drugs i hopped on a bus
and came out to la
it seemed appealing because uh i seen it
on tv skid row
and i said well it's really [__] cold
in
nashville it has to be warmer in l.a and
it can't be so lonely because there's a
large
homeless population there and the
greyhound station is two blocks down the
street
graham was right down the road i found a
mormon church that helped me
the the church i lied to them i told
them that uh
my aunt lived out here that i could move
in with her
um but my real plan was to come out here
and
wing it what was the reason
for coming to l.a why'd you choose la
all right so
it goes back to my first overdose on
heroin
my ex and i uh i would go on drug runs
by myself
i was dealing with a new dealer and uh
got a bad batch apparently it was a lot
of fentanyl
i had done the smallest little bit
because it was something that i'd never
seen before it was pure white
and i'll get to why i've discovered
anytime you get pure white powder it
tends to be
mostly fentanyl but anyway so i done
just a little bit
i was i'd never seen this kind before so
i figured i'd be careful
i was always the
uh smart one out of me and my external
drugs i was always trying to do
less less was better than more because i
had to watch over her because she had a
lot of medical problems and stuff like
that at any rate
i done i done a little bit right after i
met the dealer
and i drove from nashville back to
ashland city where i was from
where i lived and uh i don't remember
the trip driving home
i didn't make it home i didn't i don't
remember the trip driving
back to ashland city though i ended up
making it into a gas station
off the exit um i was told later
i pulled into the gas station i hit a
trash can at the gas pump and somehow i
made it into a parking spot
all i remember is i woke up on my back
outside my car
with paramedics and police officers
around me
this is where it gets [__] up
so they said they had to administer
three units of narcan on me and
i was like well can i go you know i'm
like
i'm hoping i'm not in trouble of course
and i am
so they said no you gotta go to the
hospital for observation blah blah blah
and uh so i went to the hospital
this is where the the detective comes in
the room the the hospital room and
uh lists all the charges like a lot
driving without a license driving
without a title car driving with a fake
tag
driving under the influence of a
controlled substance or
illegal substance can like [__]
10 charges and i uh i'm already on
probation in two counties
um so this could trigger two violations
plus you know so anyways he said so
let's work a deal
and this was where a lot of
a lot of problems started uh too i mean
i was already on drugs
but after the scare with the overdose at
that point
in my mind at that time i was like okay
this is where i call it quits
but the detective said why don't we make
a deal
and uh you'll work for us as a
confidential informant
and you'll bring these guys down he said
how many dealers do you know i said
this is not something i want to do he
said well you're going to be going to
prison
given that you got two violations coming
and you got about 10 charges with us
he said you want to go to jail for 10
years or you said do you want to
get rid of these charges and bring some
bad people down that are killing people
now that you look at it like that so uh
yeah i i brought down about 20 dealers
and two of them are doing life and two
of them are doing 15 years
out of the 20. so needless to say my
life became
uh my life was at risk in nashville
there was a lot of people that wanted to
kill me because i uh
you know turned a lot of people over in
the process here's
where things became problematic for me
personally
now i went to court and i
all the charges were dismissed and it
was a little entertaining because that
judge was like you apparently are a
special kind of guy around here because
this just don't happen around here
um it was actually a judge
from back 30 years ago that gave my mom
three duis
that sentenced her for three dui's
anyways so
in the process of having to entertain
going back and forth to drug dealers to
make busts
as a as a confidential informant um
it it subjected me to uh
constantly being exposed to drugs and
when you when you have a drug problem
and you've tried to decide to get away
from it but now legally you're at a
standpoint where you have to make a
decision of
staying out of jail but continuing to be
exposed to drugs it's kind of hard not
to
continue using drugs so
while dancing around probation trying
not to get a dirty urine
on two counties of probation while
trying to
get rid of charges in another county say
you don't anyway it's just all [__] up
so yeah needless to say i mean i uh
there was dealers that were exposing me
on facebook saying hey this guy's a ci
if you see him [__] kill him and uh
yeah i got messages all through my
facebook messenger saying
if we find you you're dead you better
leave nashville
so yeah i did i left nashville i kind of
took the hint
you know i beat my legal problems in
that respect in some way
um but now my life was in jeopardy so
go to jail for 10 years or you know a
risk my life and now
people want to kill me so i'm in l.a
you've been here a week
not even not even not even i think about
three days
what do you do now drugs
um it's uh i don't i don't have no plan
right now
i mean we're about to get the stimulus
money um
i don't know what to do right now i just
got to la i kind of fantasized about
coming to la
not where i'm at not not in the position
i'm in
coming here to live on skid row and do
drugs but that's where i'm at
um what do you think is playground
well they're welcoming uh
i was i wasn't here more than an hour
and i met these two african-american
guys well one african-american guy and
um we kind of we i wasn't here more than
an hour we sat down
done some drugs together and i think
that he found it appealing
when he heard me talk about how much
stimulus money i'm getting because i
have two
dependents that i got coming plus my
1400 so i'm getting like
4 200 you've been robbed yet
you will yeah
yeah we'll see about that no but uh yeah
so he found it appealing
that i you know i'm coming into some
good money and he's like hey you know i
got a tent i can put you in
and uh you know we got a blanket in
there and uh
i got access to all the dealers around
here and
and we just hang out and get high
together okay
you're in a snake pit now i'm in a snake
pit like hell
um i don't think my life's quite in
jeopardy but you know what
there is some crazy [__] that i've seen
this morning right on the corner
uh i don't know where the [__] i'm at i
don't know where anything is
but there is a corner beside this market
and there was [__] tons of blood
tons of blood and like chunks
of i don't know what and it was bloody
and uh it happened last night apparently
and somebody somebody couldn't have
survived that
it's a different it's a different
neighborhood at night than it is
yeah yeah so you know i like
i was on the bus coming here and and i
was like being warned
don't go to east l.a and be careful in
l.a and i'm like
and see all this you know i've seen skid
row on tv
i've seen la i've seen skid row on tv i
mean
you know come homeless there's drugs
there's dealers uh you expect this kind
of thing but
i didn't i didn't i didn't expect to see
all that on the corner this morning that
was just
kind of bizarre it's like this is like
you said the [__] snake put him in
and uh you know so i uh
i've been talking to my best friend in
florida and i'm like i don't know i
think i've
[__] up but i'm also finding it
appealing the scenery here you know the
mountains
i haven't made it to the beach yet and
it
is my life more in jeopardy here than it
is in nashville i don't know
my mom says i i hope i don't get a call
that you're dead
i don't know what's going to happen i
don't know where i'm headed i don't know
what's going to happen
i i don't want this life for me but
that's where i'm at
and i'm almost too comfortable with it
and i'm so very uncomfortable with at
the same time i just
everything's sober and predictable right
now i don't know what to do
your life's been full of turmoil to say
the least do you think that's because of
what happened to you is the way you were
raised i don't want to
create excuses but i mean
i had a [__] up life you know
i don't i don't use it as an excuse i
don't throw it out there and say oh this
happened to me this is why you know
but um statistics show i guess
you know this is the likely outcome of
what i've been through
how old are you 39 you're not
and you have kids three three kids
daughters 19 18 and 16.
and they're with who my 19 year old is
uh in florida living on her own
my 18 year old is just got out of uh
she was adopted out i never even knew
about her until she was five years old
um i was locked up when i got
dna paperwork and was taken to medical
to get a dna test and
then it came back that that she was my
daughter
and then later on i had a relationship
after lock up
had another daughter went back to jail
for years
and uh so i lost contact with that child
too so i haven't had the opportunity to
have
much of a relationship with my kids
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
don't do drugs kids no uh you know just
um i i would say uh
the most the biggest lesson is yeah
don't do drugs
and stay away from the streets
my dream was to be a doctor
i went to college for computer
programming but i didn't finish
because i had a daughter on the way i
couldn't afford all the bills
my ex had to quit because our daughter
was born early
um
i didn't do drugs most of my life
only uh i smoked marijuana
a gateway drug um
but uh
yeah stay away from i learned to uh
if you enter a toxic relationship with
someone that has
their own share of issues no matter the
history with that person
um no matter how much you care about
someone if if drugs are
are an issue or if there's toxicity
within the relationship
no matter how bad you want it no matter
how alone
no matter how alone you are uh stay away
from it
because uh it'll get you here
all right elijah thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you a lot of luck here in this
snake pit
yeah be careful always all right
thank you very much yes sir
you